hey youtubers is Charlie and this week
on Doctor Who some serious medieval
robot ship went down
so it was Martinez's episode and I feel
like it was a marathon of classic new
references thank you to everyone who
live tweeted the episode with me it was
always fun to do I think we did an okay
job of avoiding spoilers if you're just
finding me for the first time I doing
weekly Doctor Who videos be sure to
subscribe to get everything
I'm even doing that weekly giveaway that
I'll explain again at the end of the
video so careful for spoilers from
robota sure what if you haven't seen the
episode yet but I'm gonna start with my
top 5 moments it's all wait just a sec
ok ready here we go number 5 the doctor
spoon is mightier than the sword it had
been a long time since I had seen a
sword fighting episode of Doctor Who I
think David Tennant did some sword
fighting during Christmas invasion but
since this was a medieval episode my
mind went more to King's demons in the
time warrior but I just love how much
Capaldi hates Robin Hood from the start
like he just totally hates on him one of
my favorite quotes from the episode was
that punch in the face line I'm actually
wondering if the series is building to
that like eventually Capaldi is just
gonna pop someone in the face for anyone
who was a big fan of Star Trek that kind
of reminded me the difference between
Picard and Cisco Cisco actually punched
cue I do like thinking of Capaldi is
like the rough-and-tumble doctor like he
might actually get into a fistfight at
some point I feel like he has a lot of
9th doctor in a like a lot of that anger
like he might just jump out and strangle
one of the villains at some point I
could totally see the doctor strangling
Missy at some point but on to number 4
the doctor reacts to sherwoodforest
most of the first half of the episode
was him just calling on
everything it was just glorious the
archery contest was the icing on the
cake so the whole tone of the Robin Hood
seems like whatever Tom Riley was
jumping around being Robin Hood if that
felt strange it was because it was on
purpose
like they were doing an Errol Flynn kind
of thing I think he was meant to over
perform the role like it was all part of
this construct so that the robots could
fix their spaceship so it was like an
approximation of what Robin Hood would
act like it wasn't meant to be authentic
it was all one giant holodeck episode
and I feel like they could have done a
better job of explaining who's robot and
who was a real person also had to
because Star Trek The Next Generation
totally did a Robin Hood episode - I
could do like a whole other video on
that there's so many fandoms dreams
being crossed in my brain right now
right after the episode I will talk a
little bit more about the whole vibe of
the episode you know
whole Errol Flynn vibe in my review but
Capaldi's was tromping right through all
the pomp and ceremony was great like
Clara was going squeeze all over her
fantasy and the doctor just wanted to
stop it
I suppose you could also look at it and
like this meta way where Capaldi is like
the fandom stomping on things in Doctor
Who that they hate fun fact Steven
Moffat claims that he is the
prototypical angry Doctor Who fan like
in the years preceding the 2005 reboot
he was one of the biggest angriest
classic who fans complaining about the
state of things which really puts this
picture into a new context but on to my
number three which is kind of like an
answer to that just shut it series eight
could totally be summed up in a series
of gifs of people just telling each
other to shut it that should actually be
Capaldi's catchphrase shut it I love the
Capaldi concet that kind of angry tone
without making it off-putting like it's
really enjoyable to watch everyone just
shush each other normally I get tired of
something like that really fast but part
of me feels like the shut 'its are also
Moffat yelling back at the fandom like
if anyone remembers he used to be really
active on Twitter around series 6 I
think but by the time series 7 rolled
around he'd completely been bullied off
by crazy people just yelling at him it
didn't happen this way on purpose but
it's fun to think that he cast a very
Scottish doctor just so that he could
give him lines like that and just tell
people to shut it
technically Mark Gatiss wrote the
episode but he and Moffat have been
writing partners for such a long time he
could also kind of think of Capaldi is a
very angry version of Mycroft in the
episode but in the Sherlock Holmes Canon
Mycroft really despises the idea of
human contact so much he would probably
never leave the TARDIS think about the
Pauli's TARDIS this way now
TARDIS Diogenes Club don't you feel like
Mycroft could have like a dark corner
somewhere on the opposite side of the
TARDIS but on to number 2 The Legend of
the doctor the metaphor of the doctor as
a Time Lord Robin Hood was a little on
the nose but I still love the reference
he totally is the Robin Hood of
Gallifrey I guess that kind of makes
Rassilon the Sheriff of Nottingham
or maybe the masters of the sheriff and
wrestling's Prince John I think the real
message of Tom Raleigh's speech was the
doctor not letting his own history
burden him like he was telling the
doctor not to be weighed down in the
mire of his past mistakes the ones that
he's presumably trying to correct in
series 8 you could also view the speech
as being somewhat prophetic for his
- like he'll just turn into a legend
eventually although he kind of already
is being 2000 plus years old and all
during the Matt Smith area the legend
was all about him being a warrior like
the most dangerous man in the universe
like it was a bad thing that he was a
legend
I was wondered if it was because of the
historical things he'd done or if the
sound knew he would eventually get much
more destructive and to be fair he did
blow up the universe even though it was
to save it it is intriguing to think of
Capaldi as the fulfillment of the Cylons
prophecy the short answer to that is
that the prophecy was all about
trenzalore
and the doctor helping the Time Lords
back but let me know do you think the
Capaldi is actually the fulfillment of
that prophecy like it was all about Matt
Smith bringing the Time Lords back but
obviously he's gone now and Capaldi is
the doctor so Capaldi is going to have
to be the one to actually bring the Time
Lords back but finally my number 1
moment the Promised Land exists there
are a couple things going on here that
made this whole scene hands-down the
most fun part of the episode for me
first we get to see the Promised Land is
in fact a real place it looks kind of
like a planet but it's hard to tell it
because the rendering is incomplete
Orange so we can't see if there's any
color or if it's like a gas giant or
something else when you consider this is
the first episode to not feature Missy
it makes me feel like the Promised Land
the nethersphere in heaven are all the
same place regardless of who or what
Missy is I think we just got
confirmation that heaven is an actual
place it's not just a mainframe there
was this big reference to Evangelista
with the ice cream on the spoon at the
beginning the episode so until I saw the
picture of the Promised Land I was still
thinking that heaven could be a digital
place like the library also there was a
huge call back to the clockwork droids
in the first episode they were also
searching for the Promised Land it
wasn't clear if these robots were the
same type as the clockwork droids and
deep breath part of me feels like
they're different which would mean that
a lot of robots are searching for the
promised land Missy has been saving
robots and people so it's a little
confusing as to who is allowed into the
Promised Land so far it seems like she's
only saving people that sacrifice
themselves in the name of the doctor but
not out of spite like she's not trying
to harm the doctor the other big moment
was when the second doctor flashed on
the screen in real life in 1953 he
became the first actor to portray Robin
Hood on TV that was before he became the
doctor so this picture was taken when he
was much younger but let me know what
your favorite moment was
and let me know what are all your
promised land theories are your new ones
now that we know it's an actual place
here are actually while you're thinking
about that are a few references that I
saw in the episode some of the bigger
ones but feel free to write any
additional ones in the comments so first
off there's the spoon with the ice-cream
spoons were a big thing for the Seventh
Doctor whenever he first started his run
ice cream was a recurring subject during
the Matt Smith years and during the
silence in the library Evangelista
whispered ice cream before she faded
away then the medieval robots theme of
the episode was a huge call back to time
warrior from the third doctor's run that
was actually Sarah Jane's first big
episode as a companion and the story was
somewhat similar to in that episode a
Sontaran gives a local robber baron a
robot night while he tries to repair his
spaceship the fifth doctor also went
back to medieval times in King's demons
it was a big master episode and
introduced chameleon who went on to
become a robot companion lots of
medieval robots causing trouble in
Doctor Who history visually it felt like
the arrow shots in bullet time were a
big reference to the Kevin Costner Robin
Hood movie I seem to remember that movie
being one of the first ones to use a
camera in that way but if you ever watch
the Mel Brooks parody Men in Tights
they did a version of it where the arrow
just goes around for like 20 minutes
just doing ridiculous things before it
finds its target I feel like they did
have a little bit of fun with the arrow
just bouncing off of a bunch of
different things so then we finally hear
the robots speak I got kind of a Borg
vibe but I don't think that there are
too many overt Star Trek references in
the Doctor Who universe so you can let
me know what your opinion is on that one
but just in general there were a lot
more references to time warrior as well
as Kings demons so feel free to write
any additional references from those
episodes if you saw them there were also
a couple of other minor Matt Smith
references like Clara trying to explain
when she started believing in heroes and
then Capaldi flipped 11 sonic in the air
overall I gave the episode of B I didn't
like it quite as much as the first two
episodes and it felts a little out of
place but I do enjoy that it kind of
turned into a reaffirmation for the
doctor he's still trying to figure out
who he is look he's still wrestling with
his inner demons and I think part of the
chalkboard equations are him trying to
piece things together from his past in
addition to finding Gallifrey in
practice though I feel like a lot of the
banter with Robin Hood slowed the
episode down that was one of the few
things I didn't enjoy as much I don't
expect every episode to be as quick as
into the Dalek or deeper
but robot of Sherwood felt like it was
an episode done as a one-off and they
just weren't sure where to place it in
the run we've already been told that
series 8 is gonna feature more
standalone episodes and this was very
much a standalone I feel like because
the Missy plot is slowly gonna start to
take over the story as we get past the
halfway point they wanted to get this
episode out of the way they didn't want
it to slow down that big plot that's
going to be happening later but the
actors in general were crate Tom Riley
and Ben Miller were totally awesome as
like the Errol Flynn version of Robin
Hood and the Sheriff of Nottingham I was
a little bummed that they didn't
definitively answer whether or not Robin
Hood was a robot it seemed like Capaldi
was saying that he was like he was part
of the manufactured narrative but it
seemed like he was flesh and blood too
and at the end of the episode he was
still walking around believing that he
was the real-life Robin Hood very
confusing so in real life in history
there was a Robin Hood character but the
whole story is completely different King
Richard the Lionheart nearly bankrupt
England during the Crusades and his
brother Prince John actually tried to
save the kingdom so in the real story
Prince John is not evil I also kind of
feel like the ending with Maid Marian
was a little unnecessary if you were
confused by how she just suddenly
appeared here's what I think happened
there's actually two different
explanations I have the first is that
the doctor time-travel picked her up
dropped her off before leaving again so
it just seemed like she was appearing
out of nowhere the other explanation is
that Robin Hood
really is a construct and the doctor as
thanks to him made a Marian construct to
give him closure within his narrative
you can let me know where you fall in
like the whole Robin Hood robot not
robot spectrum but I still really
enjoyed the episode usually when there
are things in stories like this that
don't make sense is because there were
scenes that explain everything a lot
better and just got cut out at the last
minute my next bonus video is gonna be
my favorite fictional and historical
Doctor Who characters like whenever the
doctor talks about someone famous real
or not real that he's been with I'll be
posting that tonight so be sure to
subscribe to get it I'll be posting my
Q&A video tomorrow like normal so you
should have plenty of time to re-watch
the episode and think of questions
that's also where I'll announce the
winner of my giveaway remember all you
have to do to enter the weekly giveaways
is be a subscriber and just leave a
comment on any of the review videos so
right now click here to get that bonus
video ah the annotation as soon as I
post it tonight and click here to get
the Q&A video again I'll also add the
as soon as I posted tomorrow thank you
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight
high fives
you